[Music]
rekted sightings have been rare since
his split from Angelina Jolie but new
details have emerged about his life out
of the spotlight how he's dealing with
sobriety and also co-parenting meanwhile
Angelina has been out with her kids
twice in the last three days first of
all gloves and now the National Board of
Review gala Angelina made it a family
night out the actress gave a shout out
to her producing partner and her two
daughters Shiloh and Sahara last night
in New York the girls had a blast
looking adorable embraces and giggling
with mom on the red carpet the 11 year
old Shiloh's left arm was in a sling a
source tells CT she broke her collarbone
while on a family vacation in Lake Tahoe
12 days ago
all three dressed in black Angelina wore
Valentino on Sunday Angie's 14 year old
son pax accompanied her to the Golden
Globes as for Angie's ex well Brad's
post split sobriety has him in a good
place a source tells ET that Brad who
recently wrapped a new film has been
spending more time at home
another source tells us quote to Brad's
kids are his life adding that when the
children are visiting they are usually
accompanied by bodyguards and nannies
vows is basically on lockdown
[Music]
you